in the past two months Kanye West has
lost 79 of his wealth he went from being
worth 1.9 billion dollars to just 400
million dollars in less than eight weeks
what yeah I mean
I don't you know
what's going on this is the unbelievable
fall of Kanye West
I love Jewish people but I also love
Nazis
oh man well I have to disagree with that
once was widely considered as one of the
most Brilliant Minds in music and just
when you thought he said the wildest
thing ever he continues to up the ante
the rapper yay formerly known as Kanye
West got his Twitter account suspended
again for making anti-semitic posts this
is going to be catastrophic
how did we get here let's hit rewind
October 3rd 2022 Paris Fashion Week in
France in the middle of one of the most
prestigious fashion events on the planet
something was brewing over at the Yeezy
show a scene that had become all too
familiar an outlandish display by the
one and only Kanye West
that I am the leader see during his
runway show Kanye actually sent models
down the runway wearing white lives
matter shirts he also wore one himself
according to him he quote thought the
shirt was a funny shirt and thought the
idea of me wearing it was funny end
quote
obviously people are outraged and going
nuts about it on the internet come on
dude everyone all lies better I think he
needs to shut up he needs more education
before he speaks I don't think he meant
for it to be hateful all lives matter
for sure definitely we agree with Conway
Kanye but Kanye doesn't stop there
instead he keeps up the performance on
Instagram and Twitter for the world to
see spewing confusing erratic and
straight up anti-semitic messages which
just Riles people up more and when other
celebrities started calling him out
Kanye just started attacking them all
online he said it was war it didn't take
long for his accounts to be banned on
Instagram and Twitter but still he was
nowhere near finished on October 11th
one day after being banned from Twitter
Kanye joins an interview with Tucker
Carlson to explain his actions at Paris
fashion week but nothing he says makes
any sense I did I do certain things from
a feeling I like I just I just this
channel the energy it just feels right
it is easier to make beats than think
five days later Kanye goes on another
show called drink Champs where his story
gets even more deluded and anti-semitic
he even said how he liked Hitler's ideas
every human being has something of value
that they brought to the table
especially Hitler she's singing from
Jesus
this time though he took it one step
further he called out his most
profitable business partner Adidas
I could say anti-semitic things and
Adidas can't drop me and that definitely
struck a chord
Kanye brutally called out the company
that was the reason for the vast
majority of his wealth saying that they
would never ever dare to stop working
with him and what did Adidas do yup it
only took a little over a week before
Adidas proved Kanye wrong just like that
poof almost his entire Fortune was gone
and Adidas wasn't the only one
Balenciaga and Vogue said that they
wouldn't work with Kanye West ever again
Gap said it would be removing any
remaining Yeezy products from their
stores JP Morgan reportedly unbanked him
his lawyers announced they are no longer
representing him creative artists agency
CAA who ran his music tours dropped him
an entertainment company that was
supposed to make a documentary about his
life even stopped production nobody
wanted anything to do with Kanye West
and his antics
All Things Considered Kanye himself
claims he lost 2 billion dollars in a
single day in weeks Kanye West went from
being one of the richest and most
in-demand business people in the country
to an industry Pariah that nobody wants
to work with one who's on the fast track
to becoming completely broke but that's
only a fraction of the insane story
behind Kanye West's rise and fall
the whole truth is even wilder than you
could ever imagine stay dangerous
subscribe for more and this is Kanye
West the rise and fall of a billionaire
ah
[Applause]
the Kanye Adidas partnership counted for
almost one tenth of Adidas's total sales
last year but even before canceling it
their stock had fallen off a cliff down
around 60 percent YTD sure Kanye lost
some 1.6 billion but real people are
hurting with dreams and retirements put
on hold not because of Adidas
specifically of course even the classic
strategy of stock and bond investing has
lost between 15 and 25 percent its worst
performance in 90 years as a result
expert institutions like Goldman Sachs
say portfolios need to be rebalanced to
avoid more losses they highlighted real
assets because real assets have
previously outperformed in volatile
conditions like these like Fine Art
which Goldman specifically says can
protect your purchasing power in these
conditions in fact the Paul Allen
auction just broke records fetching over
1.6 billion with 65 percent of paintings
selling over their highest estimate no
wonder Masterworks is seeing increased
demand because they let you invest in
multi-million dollar paintings from
Legends like Picasso we've talked about
Masterworks since 2021 these are not
nfts and there's an offering circular
with the SCC for each offering which
we've Linked In the description and you
know what during the time it took us to
edit this video Masterworks sold another
painting this one for an insane
13.9 net return that brings their last
three sales to 13 17 and 21 net returns
Masterworks has over 600 000 users so
paintings have sold out in minutes
before but your account will be
pre-loaded with special access when you
use the link in the description so pause
the video and click the link below to
join Masterworks now thanks to
Masterworks for sponsoring this video
according to almost everyone who knew
him Kanye West was a special Kid born in
Atlanta Georgia in 1977 Kanye Omari West
is the only child of donda and Ray West
his mother was an English professor at
Chicago State University and his father
was a well-respected photojournalist and
former black panther his parents
divorced when he was three and even
though his mom raised him by herself she
said that she always saw similarities
between Kanye and his father quote like
his dad Kanye has little patience for
what he thinks is unjust end quote donda
was a huge influence in support on
Kanye's life once she realized he had a
keen sense for music she did everything
she could to help him follow his
passions when Kanye was only 13 she paid
for him to cut his first single record
in a basement Studio quote the
microphone was hanging from the ceiling
by a wire hanger but he was so excited I
couldn't say no end quote the track was
called quote Green Eggs and Ham end
quote the first official song by Kanye
West Kanye went to college for a year
but eventually decided to drop out and
pursue music his mother agreed and gave
him one year to make it in the industry
or figure something else out but he
didn't just become an overnight
sensation in the end it took years of
learning how to make music working with
producers and even working as a Sears
telemarketer before Kanye broke into the
real music world Kanye started off
selling B beats to rappers for a few
thousand dollars a piece eventually his
work started catching the attention of
bigger artists like Jay-Z by then it
seemed like Kanye's career was really
taking off he produced five of the 13
tracks on Jay-Z's iconic album The
Blueprint and even got signed to
Rockefeller records
but everything changed in 2002 when
Kanye was almost killed in a horrific
car accident and in an insane twist of
fate it would take him from being a
little-known producer and rapper to a
worldwide musical Legend
foreign
on the morning of October 23 2002 Kanye
West woke up in a Los Angeles hospital
with his jaw completely wired shut after
falling asleep at the wheel and crashing
his car he was left with a completely
broken jaw it was a tragic turn of
events that could have easily destroyed
his career as a musician in an instant
but that wouldn't happen to Kanye West
the entire ordeal actually inspired
Kanye in a way he had never experienced
before Kanye's friend said quote he was
like I figured it out I was like what
did you figure out he said I'm going to
rap about this accident I'm going to use
a song and change the direction I'm
going conscious with my music end quote
just two weeks after his accident he
created a mixtape called Through the
Wire while his jaw was literally still
wired shut it would include one of his
most famous songs to date the music
industry and the whole country were so
impressed that he recorded his very
first album in 2004 The College Dropout
Kanye described the album by saying
quote all the album is saying is make
your own decisions don't let Society
tell you this is what you have to do end
quote it was a hit landing at number two
on the billboard 200 albums chart almost
immediately in winning the 2004 Grammy
for best rap album of the Year suddenly
everyone knew the name Kanye West the
musical genius from that point on he
didn't slow down every year he released
new music making more money and becoming
even more famous his music brought
something new to the table Kanye West
was achieving all his Wildest Dreams in
the music industry and getting very rich
doing it but he wanted more than that he
wanted to break into new Industries and
explore his other passions and that
would be the decision that put him on
the fast track to billionaire them
[Music]
it's 2008. Kanye is at the top of his
game with his rap career in the bag
Kanye West had his eye on a new Venture
fashion so he partnered with Nike to
create his own shoes the Air Yeezys when
the shoes dropped the public ate it up
they sold out almost immediately then in
2013 Kanye released the Air Yeezy 2 to
the same Global reaction but he still
wanted more so not long after the launch
of their second shoe Kanye left Nike in
a very public departure Kanye said that
Nike refused to pay him royalties for
the sales of his own shoe and instantly
decided to take his wildly successful
brand over to one of their biggest
competitors Adidas Kanye West had
already achieved more wealth and success
than most of us could even dream of but
partnering with Adidas took it to enough
Other Extreme the Yeezy streetwear brand
expanded into other fashion niches
Beyond shoes like jackets sweaters and
accessories and the products were all
extremely in demand retailers couldn't
keep the shelves stocked with Yeezy
items for more than a day before they
sold out Yeezy stood out from other
brands on the market because it was
exclusive and limited only a few hundred
items in every style were produced and
once they were gone they were gone for
good after one Yeezy pop-up shop in 2016
Kanye said that he sold one million
dollars worth of clothes in just two
days and it was just uphill from there
in 2020 after only a decade in the
fashion industry Kanye West became a
billionaire the top
.0001 he officially had it all money
Fame power success and that's
it all started coming apart at the scene
first half of Kanye's epic career most
people regarded him as a musical and
entrepreneurial genius but most of all
he was very outspoken like in 2005 after
Hurricane Katrina when celebrities got
together for a Telethon to raise
donation funds when the cameras were
finally put on him Kanye had fist to say
George Bush doesn't care about black
people
Kanye West had been making headlines for
his weird statements and behavior pretty
much since he first got famous but most
people just accepted this as part of
Kanye's image lots of fans even
appreciated his honesty and
outrageousness at first and then the MTV
Music Video Awards happened in 2009 and
things kinda took a turn Taylor Swift
won the award for best female video and
was just about to make her acceptance
speech when Kanye famously stormed the
stage
I'm really happy for you I'll let you
finish but Beyonce had one of the best
videos of all time
that moment changed something for Khan
changed the way the public perceived him
over the next few years he got caught up
in a lot of different scandals from
tweeting his support for Bill Cosby
after allegations were made against him
to putting on disastrous fashion shows
he was no longer The Lovable Loose
Cannon who spoke his mind freely now he
was a bully but even that didn't hurt
his career too much Kanye West kept
selling records and clothes and kept
making more money every year until 2018
when he decided to take it up a notch
you hear about slavery for 400 years for
400 years that sounds like a choice
I love this guy right here Kanye ended
up saying things like slavery was a
choice he would make strange speeches
whenever he was given a moment of air
time like on SNL and after making his
new political stance very clear Kanye
decided he wanted to get into a third
business that he'd never tried before
politics
so in 2020 he announced that he would be
running for president and he was very
serious he didn't even come close to
winning but it was obvious that Kanye
was going more over the top than he ever
had before and the more time that went
by the more questionable Kanye's
Behavior became like harassing his
ex-wife Kim Kardashian making veiled
death threats against her new boyfriend
opening a mysterious elite private
school named after his late mother that
was shut down soon after opening all of
that led up to Kanye's latest stunts
that cost him billions of dollars and
all that Fame he'd worked so hard for
now the only question is can Kanye West
ever come back from the hole he's dug
himself into
foreign
had an uncanny ability to bounce back
from controversy year after year he kept
growing his wealth and influence despite
being the center of more scandals than
most celebrities see in their lifetime
but this time seems different even
before all his recent incidents Kanye
was slowly being cut out of the
entertainment industry he was disinvited
from performing at the Grammy Awards in
2021. he withdrew from headlining the
Coachella Festival in 2022 only a week
before it began everyone is getting as
far away from Kanye West as possible at
the rate he's going Kanye could go
completely broke any day now as the
guardian puts it Kanye West is a toxic
asset and he knows it that's why he
showed up unannounced and uninvited to
the Skechers headquarters after being
dumped by Adidas he was kicked out of
the building by Executives after trying
to film The Encounter and Skechers made
it very clear that they are not
considering and have no intention of
working with Kanye West ever Kanye West
was one of the most Innovative music
artists and Brilliant entrepreneurs of
our time he built up an unbelievable
career and a multi-billion dollar
Fortune only for it all to be
obliterated in a matter of months and
right now it looks like all that bad
publicity is making a comeback next to
Impossible
so what do you guys think of Kanye I
personally have always been rather
indifferent towards this music it was
never my thing but what do you think if
you're new here this is one of the
biggest shows on YouTube for
documentaries on money power war and
crime so if you like this video click
that subscribe button below but that is
going to wrap it up stay dangerous out
there and I will see you guys in the
next one
[Music]
[Music]